next a hearing on allegations of CIA
involvement in cocaine trafficking
yesterday the Senate Intelligence
Committee chaired by Senator Arlen
Specter of Pennsylvania heard testimony
from inspectors general from the CIA and
the justice system recently the San Jose
Mercury News ran a series of articles on
the CIA and drug trafficking
the hearings two and a half hours well
just committee will proceed
the subject of today's hearings involves
the allegations of CIA involvement in
the United States drug sales to finance
the Contras in the Nicaraguan war this
is the first day when Senator Kerry and
I could get together after the Senate
recess we are going to proceed today in
our oversight capacity on the Central
Intelligence Agency we are going to hear
from witnesses Jack Blum who was
formerly counsel to the
Senate Foreign Relations subcommittee
and the Inspector General's from the
Department of Justice and also the CIA
to outline the scope of the
investigation which will be undertaken
on this important matter during the
course of the past several weeks I've
been engaging in a series of town
meetings around my state Pennsylvania
and I note an extraordinarily high level
of distrust of the government and so
many many lines we see the militia
movement we see what had happened in a
small Township Bradford Pennsylvania
interest in a 20 year old shooting of a
man named Leonard Peltier and yesterday
we noted the filing of an information in
the events relating to Ruby Ridge we
intend to move through these oversight
hearings very much as the subcommittee
of judiciary did is two year ago this
time on the hearings of Ruby Ridge we
heard some 62 witnesses over 14 days of
hearings and came out with findings
right down the middle and found general
satisfaction of what the Oversight
Committee did in that situation and this
is a matter particularly suited for
oversight
I'm not saying how many hearings we're
going to have or precisely what we are
going to do because we're going to have
to see how the matter and folds but it
is a matter of some considerable
interest and in this
achieve quite a high level of
recognition around the country I'm going
to take a little longer than usual today
to set the stage with the summary of the
matters as they have appeared in the
public media beginning August 18th of
this year the San Jose Mercury News ran
a three-day series purporting to trace
the origins of crack cocaine epidemic to
a pair of Nicaraguan drug traffickers
with connections to the US backed
Contras the series was entitled Dark
Alliance the story behind the crack
explosion in stating what the San Jose
Mercury found we do not accept them and
we do not endorse them but merely
outlined these allegations to set the
stage for the testimony which we are
going to hear today the series focused
on the activities of two Nicaraguans
Oscar Danilo Blandon rays and Juan or
van mrs. Cantor arrow and a Los Angeles
drug dealer named Ricky Ross
Blandon had served as a minor official
in the government of former Decker
Oakland dictator Anastasio Somoza
Blandon fled Nicaragua before the
Sandinistas came to power and ended up
in California he entered a guilty plea
in 1992 to conspiracy to distribute
cocaine and serve 28 months upon release
he became a DEA informant and in March
1995 testified against Rick Ross Meneses
is currently serving time at a
Nicaraguan jail for a 1992 conviction on
cocaine trafficking Meneses comes from a
prominent Nicaraguan family longtime
supporters of the Somoza regime his
older brother was a general and Somozas
national guard in chief of the National
Police Meneses has a long history of
involvement in drug trafficking as early
as 1976 the DIA identified him as a
cocaine supplier in Managua
he fled to the United States when the
Somoza regime collapsed was indicted by
a grand jury in the United States in
1989 Ross also known as freeway wreck is
a 36 year old african-american from
South Central Los Angeles in the 1980s
he became a major cocaine dealer in Los
Angeles rising to such prominence that
local authorities formed a freeway Rick
task force so-called in 1986 and
according to the Mercury News series of
what I'm reciting now comes from that
series and as I say we don't accept it
or endorse it but are repeating it in
1987 Ross moved to Cincinnati for a
cooling-off period and in 1991 was
arrested convicted and sentenced to 10
years for establishing a cocaine
distribution ring and since an atom that
sentence was cut in half after he agreed
to testify against Los Angeles narcotic
agents accused of corruption 1995 he was
arrested in a DEA sting involving
Blondin and was convicted in March 96 of
conspiracy to distribute cocaine and as
awaiting sentence the Mercury News
Series further alleges that in 1981
Blandon became involved with efforts to
help the Nicaraguan Contras through
largely unsuccessful fundraising rallies
and parties Blandon met Meneses who
encouraged him to sell cocaine to raise
money so says the mercury series Meneses
took Blandon to Honduras to meet a
contra military leaner Colonel and reak
Bermudez Blandon has testified that
Bermudez told him that the quote ends
justify the means close quote
and although Bermudez never mentioned
drug trafficking Blandon began selling
cocaine supplied by Meneses to raise
money for the Contras sometime between
1982 and 1983 according to the Mercury
News series Blandon began supplying
cocaine to Ross who marketed it in the
predominantly african-american
neighborhoods in South Central Los
Angeles again according to the
three news series Ross termed the
powdered cocaine into crack and became a
major dealer in Los Angeles according to
that series Meneses applied Blandon he
supplied Ross with a seemingly quote
seemingly inexhaustible supply of high
grain cocaine close quote
the Nicaraguan supposedly laundered
their profits through a bank in Florida
back to the Contra organization the FT n
run by a doleful Calero the series
refers to this as the F D ends drug
operation the series also makes what
could be characterized as veiled
references to possible CIA interference
in the investigation and prosecution of
bland ism Meneses in discussing Meneses
long history of drug trafficking and the
unsuccessful investigation conducted
against him the series says quote
records and interviews revealed that a
number of these probes were stymied not
by the elusive Vanessa's but by agencies
of the US government the article
continues quote agents from for
organizations DEA US Customs the Los
Angeles County Sheriff's Department on
the California Bureau of Narcotics
Enforcement have complained that
investigations were hampered by the CIA
or unnamed national security interest
close quote and we will do whatever is
possible to get to the bottom of that
allegation since the series ran in late
August several members of Congress have
called for an investigation and the
director of the Office of National Drug
Control Policy general McCaffrey has
also called for a review of the matter
director of Central Intelligence guides
testified before this committee of the
CIA's intent to investigate and he
outlined that a preliminary review found
those signs of CIA involvement in any
such activity the San Jose Mercury News
series caused considerable national
concern because of the question as to
whether the US government bears
responsibility for the crack cocaine
epidemic several major newspapers have
independently examined the allegations
of the Mercury News and reached
different conclusions the following is a
very brief summary of some of those
newspaper findings and is the case with
the San Jose Mercury the committee does
not accept or endorse any of those
findings but will repeat them to provide
to provide some balance as we begin this
hearing the other newspapers noted that
the link and establishing and alleged
connection between the rise of crack
cocaine and the CIA supported Contras is
the role of blindness and Meneses the
Mercury News series characterizes bland
and Meneses as contra leaders saying
that Blanda was one of the founders of
the fdn in California according to the
other analysis The Mercury News offers
little support for this claim beyond a
photograph the Meneses and the fdn
leader Adolfo Guerrero
and bland is assertion that he was
selling drugs out of his sense of
patriotism the New York Times says quote
neither of the two ever held an official
position in any of the Nicaraguan groups
close quote the Los Angeles Times
concluded that Meneses gave less than
$50,000 to the Contra effort and
blandest participation was even more
limited other press reports have
questioned the linkage between bland ins
dealings with Ross and the Contra effort
Landon's testimony indicates that to the
time he started selling to Ross he had
stopped using Meneses as his principal
supplier and was dealing directly with
the Colombians Blanda also testified but
after his break with Meneses in 1982 or
83 he was not sending money to the
Contras but was in business for himself
it was only in late 1983 that he began
his association with Ross and according
to these other new series of Blandon was
buying from the Colombians then selling
to Ross and pocketing the profits there
is no connection so say these other
analysts
between the CIA back Contras and the
crack that Ross was peddling on the
streets of Los Angeles
Paul sources acknowledged that Meneses
and Blandon trafficked in cocaine but
most have questioned the
characterization that they fostered the
crack epidemic The Washington Post
reported that Blandon based on law
enforcement estimates in his own
accounts handled about five tons of
cocaine over his 10-year career that is
obviously a significant amount but it is
2/10 of 1% of the nationwide cocaine
trade and raises the question as to
whether the Mercury News accurately
characterized him as the quote Johnny
Appleseed of crack in California close
quote
according to the other analyses law
enforcement and academic experts
discount the hypotheses that any one
individual or organization was
responsible for the growth of crack the
epidemic was driven so they say by a
combination of factors that began
appearing across the country nearly
simultaneously these other news analyses
concluded that Ross was a major Los
Angeles crack dealer but one of many in
Blandon of an essence were mid-level
traffickers he sympathized with the
Contras and probably donated a smaller
money to the cause in the early 1980s
and the other news analysis say the trio
was not directly connected to the
Nicaraguan Contras or the CIA and the
rise of crack cocaine would have
occurred regardless of their
participation that I say is a very brief
setting as to what has appeared in the
public medium and this is obviously a
matter of very very substantial
importance the news stories directly
implicate the Central Intelligence
Agency this committee has direct
oversight responsibilities for the
Central Intelligence Agency and we
intend to see to it that all the facts
are laid before the American public so
that we can follow those facts and draw
whatever conclusions are warranted and
as I say today's hearing is just the
beginning where we will hear from a
former investigation by
subcommittee the Committee on Foreign
Relations not the Intelligence Committee
and what investigations are now planned
by the CIA itself and the Department of
Justice and this committee itself will
be doing considerably further I now
yield to my distinguished colleague the
Vice Chairman senator Kennedy senator
Kerry thank you very much mr. chairman
and prescribe a do support strongly your
decision to convene this hearing on
these very important allegations that
have been made against the CIA for its
actions during the Reagan administration
until we have the data however which the
inspectors general before us today will
uncover our hearing must be tentative
and inconclusive but it can serve at
least one very important purpose it can
signal the seriousness and determination
of this committee to learn the truth and
to act upon it this is a very
inflammatory subject to say the least
either the CIA a US government agency
approved or condoned the introduction
sale of crack cocaine to Americans in
order to finance and Nicaraguan Contras
during the regular administration or the
people who served in the CIA at the time
many of whom was still serving have been
erroneously accused we have a duty to
get the bottom of these allegations and
as we do so I'm confident we'll be
guided by the evidence and the evidence
only speaking of confidence I know mr.
hits the CIA inspector general very well
and I know the statute which makes him
completely independent from from CIA
management so I have confidence in his
ability to get to the facts and a report
then
now the audience we're good at we're
going to ask that the proceedings be
conducted in accordance with our regular
rules and we'll hear the witnesses and
we'll ask some questions we've asked for
no response from the audience believes
and I'd say to the audience who chose
understandable cynicism about my
statement that mr. hits has been on many
occasions many occasions under a great
deal of pressure from the CIA as a
consequence of his honest and direct
evaluation their performance and on many
occasions of former directors have
actually come before our committee and
asked that he be removed because he's
done such a thorough job of evaluating
so I do not praise and mr. hits and say
that I believe that his IG report will
provide and we will make to the extent
possible at information public so it can
be examined I do not make a
complimentary remark about mr. hits in
order to cover for the CIA I do it
because I believe the the IGS report
which is initiated as a consequence of
the CIA's concern or for what is going
on
I believe that report is going to be
enormous ly constructive and I look
forward to the work product
I do not know mr. Bromwich but I had the
same a very high expectation that we
have had on mr. hits when he has
examined many of these things in the
past I would say parenthetically as well
one of the difficulties that we have is
that when we recruit men and women who
work whether it's for the Central
Intelligence Agency or the FBI whoever
they're working for we asked them to do
many things and we asked them to do
above all to keep what they do in secret
is a very difficult environment these
men and women have families these men
and women love their country they're
trying to the best of their ability to
do their job I I believe that they
should be afforded the same presumption
of innocent until proven guilty that
every other American is given regardless
of the truth of the specific allegation
from the Mercury News I believe we must
also step basket and step back and ask
how America was affected when the Reagan
administration made the policy decision
that calm
in Nicaragua and not drug-trafficking
was America's top priority in Latin
America this policy choice may have made
it easier for the cocaine cartels to
build their business in this country and
it may it play CIA personnel and contact
they otherwise would not have had with
drug traffickers if the worlds of covert
action and drug trafficking bumped into
each other we need to know how CIA
people reacted and whether those
reactions would be any different under
today's rules mr. chairman emotion can
be the enemy of evidence but the
emotional reaction to these allegations
sends a powerful message it is our duty
as elected officials to listen to the
message learn from it and act on what we
learn the message I am hearing is a
deep-seated cynicism and hostility
towards government and its motives on
the part of many in the african-american
community they contrast they contrast
the government's military and scientific
prowess with its failure a long-running
bipartisan failure mr. chairman to keep
drugs from ruining their families and
their neighborhoods and they conclude
their government is at best indifferent
to them from their perspective the war
on drugs is war against the people of
our own inner cities not against those
who mastermind and profit from this
trade and we look at the great majority
of those in prison for drug offenses you
can hardly argue with this point of view
if we were to bring something positive
out of these allegations mr. chairman we
must hear this message we must work
across party lines with the
administration and with state and local
government to put in place counter drug
programs which everyone in the country
including those in the inner city can
see are effective and are for the
benefit of all Americans a democratic
government can't last very long if many
of its own people view it as an enemy
thank you much very much senator Kerry
I would underscore what you have said in
one respect about the cynicism and it is
not only the african-american community
which is cynical about what goes on in
the government and I would refer again
to the hearings that Ruby Ridge where
there was great cynicism as to what the
FBI did and the alcohol Tobacco and
Firearms unit and subcommittee in this
very room just a year ago at this time
as I had said earlier conducted 14
hearings and heard sixty two witnesses
and produced 155 page report and while
it's taken the Justice Department some
time and I suggest too long they did
file the criminal charge yesterday
against a very high-ranking FBI official
and the responsibility really is lodged
on Oversight with the Congress we have
that responsibility we'll hear today
from executive officials but the buck
comes to the Congress of the United
States and this committee will discharge
its responsibilities fairly and fully we
like now to have the mr. rum hits and
mr. Bromwich step forward and I would
yield now to Senator Roth who is joining
us mr. Chairman I thank you I have no
opening statement the allegations are
serious and deserve the thorough inquiry
and evaluation I look forward to hearing
the testimony of our opening witness and
subsequently to the investigations that
the Inspector General will conduct and I
will suspend any conclusions until that
time I thank you
we'd like to proceed now to hear all
three witnesses seriatim and then we
will have questions so if we could have
as I say mr. hits and mr. Bromwich step
forward and be seated at the witness
table and we turn to you first mr. bloom
Jack bloom is the former special counsel
to the Senate Foreign Relations
Subcommittee
beyond terrorism narcotics and
international operations and that
subcommittee conducted an extensive
inquiry and filed an extensive report
back in 1989 and we're very interested
in those findings at that time and we
now turn to you mr. chairman I very much
appreciate the invitation to appear here
this morning I find it ironic in a way
that I'm here in the same room where we
began hearings on the same subject in
1988 in January of 1988 we began the
investigation in 1987 the questions you
put this morning are questions which are
extraordinarily important the question
of reform of the intelligence community
really requires that these issues be
debated publicly and discussed publicly
and I would hope that the inquiry goes
beyond the narrow questions posed in the
San Jose Mercury News story the answer
you get to the questions you ask depends
totally on how you frame a question if
you ask the question did the CIA sell
drugs in the black neighborhoods of Los
Angeles to finance the Contra war the
answer will be a categorical no the fact
of the matter is we found no evidence
whatsoever to suggest that there was a
targeting of the african-american
community cocaine in the mid 80s and
into the early 90s was a perfect equal
opportunity destroyer we had addiction
and problems in schoolyards across
America it didn't matter what color you
were where you were from what your
national origin was the problem became
more acute in the african-american
community because the definition of a
problem addict in America is an addict
who runs out of money and if you run out
of money quickly you become involved in
the drug trade you become a visible
social problem and you get on the screen
in fact the stockbrokers the
entertainers the lawyers who use cocaine
around America escape that attention
but their lives were ruined too perhaps
not financially the second issue is did
the CIA do the selling of the cocaine
and did the Contras profit and as far as
we were able to determine no member of
the staff of the CIA that is someone on
the payroll as opposed to people they
work with
was in the cocaine business and
certainly no one on the staff of the CIA
as far as we could determine was
actively selling the drug and then
finally the question of was he used to
support the conference I will tell you
of two meetings that I had with contra
veterans one in 1986 and one in 1989 at
the beginning in the end of my
investigation and they said our problem
was we never had any money
our leadership stole most of it they had
houses in Miami they had opportunities
to gamble they had girlfriends they
traveled and we were in the field and
one of the groups that I talked to had
men who lost their arms and their eyes
and their legs fighting the Sandinistas
we in the field had none of the benefit
so I submit what went on led to the
profits of people in the Contra movement
not to supporting a war that we were
trying to advance now having said that
we have to go back to what is true and
what is true is the policymakers
absolutely closed their eyes to the
criminal behavior of our allies and
supporters in that war the policymakers
ignored their drug dealing their
stealing and their human rights
violations the policymakers and I stress
policymakers allowed them to compensate
themselves for helping us in that war by
remaining silent in the face of their
impropriety and by quietly undercutting
law enforcement and human rights
agencies but might have caused them
difficulty we knew about the connection
between the West Coast cocaine trade and
the Contras
there was an astonishing case called the
case in that case I believe it was in
that case the United States attorney for
San Francisco a man by the name of Russa
nello returned thirty five thousand
dollars of cocaine proceeds voluntarily
to the Contras when it had been seized
as the proceeds of drug trafficking
we found that absolutely astonishing I
know of no other situation where the
Justice Department was so forthcoming
in returning seized property was that
the Justice Department or the District
Attorney of the San Francisco this was a
Justice Department the United States
Attorney that's correct
we had a telephone conversation with mr.
Russa nello asking him to provide us
documents and access to the people
involved in the case and he shouted at
us he shouted at Senator John Kerry who
chaired the committee he accused us of
being subversive for wanting to go into
it it should be stress that the blonde
on Manassas ring was part of a very much
larger picture and to give you an idea
of how large that picture was there was
a point where the wholesale price of
cocaine on the street in Los Angeles
reached twenty-five hundred dollars a
kilo we were talking about cocaine that
was available in such quantity they
could not find buyers twenty-five
hundred dollars a kilo according to all
the experts is below cost and that that
is a flood of cocaine and our friend
Freeway Ricky was touching only a tiny
fraction of what was coming in we had a
definite cocaine epidemic now you might
ask why did the hearings we run in 1989
and the report we released and the
hearings we ran in 88 the report route
we released in 1989 not get more
attention and the answer is we were
subject to a systematic campaign to
discredit everything we did every night
after there was a public hearing Justice
Department people administration people
would get on the phone and call the
press and say the witnesses
were all liars they were talking to us
to get a better deal that we were on a
political vendetta that none of it was
to be believed and please don't cover it
the consequence of that was the hearing
and the report were given very modest
play in the press I think the report and
the hearing as you go into this matter
and look at some of the transcripts and
I do hope you'll get the actual records
and closed session and deposition
hearings from the archives where they
all are and I hope all of that is made
public you'll find we did a rather
thorough job it was a systematic effort
to discredit us that prevented the
conclusions from receiving the attention
I believe they warranted now I would
argue that over a period a long period
of years covert operations were
undertaken and it's not only the CIA
obviously the decision in that areas of
a political level and the CIA would be
an implementing agency
we're taken on an ideological basis that
verged on religious belief and with an
eye to short-term results and not
long-term consequences never again
should that kind of ideological
blindness and short-term vision in fact
intelligence assessments in the 1980's
all of us could count the number of
people dead on the streets of America as
a result of the drug problem you
couldn't find me a single person in
America who had died as a result of an
attack by a sandanista inside our
borders there should have been some
ability to notice that distinction and
understand the importance of the drug
problem and understand that that had to
be addressed and at the very least that
anything you did to solve any other
foreign policy problem not make the drug
problem worse
I think that among the other things you
should be looking at is a review of the
relationship in general
between covert operations and criminal
organizations the two go together like
love and marriage and it's a problem
which really has to be understood by
this committee criminal organizations
are perfect allies in a covert operation
if you sent me out of the country to
risk my life for the government to do
something as a spy in a foreign land
I would think criminals would be my best
ally they stay out of reach of the law
they know who the corrupt government
officials are and they have them on the
payroll they'll do anything I want for
money
it's a terrific working partnership the
problem is that they then get empowered
by the fact that they work with us so
now they have stature and influence and
an impact in their own country and if
they have influence with politicians and
people who come to power we now have a
new powerful criminal enterprise and we
can't always control what they do once
we stand down and unfortunately we have
yet to figure out how to prevent
criminal friends from becoming an
albatross there's a second problem and
that is when you run covert operations
you train people in a lot of skills
unfortunately the story of Adam and Eve
stays with us once you learn something
once you've bitten the apple of
knowledge you can't unlearn it ever and
we teach people how to change their
identity how to hide from the law how to
build bonds how to assassinate people
they don't forget how to do it and you
wind up after the covert action is over
with a disposal problem
we've never been very good at handling
disposal we had that problem in the Bay
of Pigs Bay of Pigs veterans have turned
up in everything from Watergate to the
let le a assassination there's a list
that's so long it's painful to recount
now
the connection with a drug trade and I
had to go into much of this in in
preparation for the hearing and we heard
it again and again from people we talked
to goes way back we were involved in
assisting the Kuomintang armies against
mount Satan in the 1950s during that
period we supported people who were in
the heroin trade in the mountains of
Burma and Bo's Kuomintang Tong Army's
help themselves and financed themselves
out of the heroin business it turned up
again in the Vietnam War where our
allies the Hmong tribesmen were in the
heroin business
there were many accusations and all
kinds of stories about was the CIA
dealing heroin and the answer was we're
not doing it probably true it's our
allies and we have to work with whoever
we have to work with in Afghanistan
recently we've had allies who went into
the Aero and business big Don it's a
largest cash crop in Afghanistan it's a
most important export from the region
it's coming out by the ton and we also
have a disposal problem we have all
kinds of people have been trained in
bomb-making and by God they've been with
us everywhere from the World Trade
Center to Paris and all over the world
wherever there's somebody who doesn't
suit their own ideological tenor now to
turn specifically to the Latin American
story and where our investigation picks
up on the drug trail we had testimony
from a man who was a civilian employee
of Argentine military intelligence
Leandro Sanchez Reis he told us that the
United States had occur encouraged the
Argentine military to act as proxy for
the United States during the Carter
Administration because we had a public
policy of supporting human rights and
another policy of really trying to
sustain or any communist efforts and the
Argentine
he said sponsored the cocaine coup in
Bolivia and then set up a
money-laundering operation in Fort
Lauderdale and we later checked and
indeed he had set up that operation and
he used the money-laundering operation
in Fort Lauderdale to provide funds to
the Argentine's all over Latin America
who were in the business of quote
fighting communism we should remember
that it was the Argentine's who were the
original trainers of the Contras they
were the ones who brought the original
Contras to Honduras Guatemala and began
to teach them how to do what they had to
do against the sandanista government
Sanchez Reis told us that he believed
that the reason the Argentine's were so
willing to go to war with the British
over the Falklands was that the
Argentine generals seriously thought
that the assistance they had given us
the covert assistance they had given us
was going to put them in our good races
to the point where we would side with
them a tragic mistake indeed if he was
correct the second man who turned up on
our screen very big time was general
Noriega and as you'll recall press
accounts have said it the government has
it has made this public so I'm not
saying anything that's classified
Noriega was on our payroll the accounts
we heard were that he was getting paid
some two hundred thousand dollars a year
by the United States government at the
time that was going on virtually
everybody who dealt with and knew he was
in the drug business it was an open
secret in fact it was so open it
appeared on the front page of the New
York Times in June of 1986 I testified
about it in the closed session of the
Foreign Relations Committee in 1986 we
have as the absolute low point of the
Contra war
our ally north having a meeting with
with general Noriega and he recorded
that meeting in great detail in his
notebooks in which he's bargaining with
Noriega Noriega says to him I've got
this terrible public relations problem
over drugs what can you do to help me
here's what I'll do to help you I'll
assassinate the entire sandanista
leadership I'll blow up buildings in
Managua Ali doesn't call the cops what
all he does is he goes back to
Poindexter and Poindexter says gee
that's a little bit extreme can't you
get him to tone it down go back and meet
with him again which all he does when
our committee asked the General
Accounting Office to do a step-by-step
analysis of just who in our government
knew the general Noriega was dealing
drugs and when they knew it and what
they did to act on that knowledge the
administration told every agency of the
government not to cooperate with Gao
labeled in a national security matter
and swept it into the White House and
cloaked it and executive privilege that
investigation never went forward should
have gone forward I was very much
dismayed our committee subpoenaed Ollie
North's notebooks and the history of
those notebooks is quite astonishing not
many people realize this but the Senate
never got a clean copy of those
notebooks North's lawyers were permitted
to expurgate sections of the notebooks
based on quote relevance our committee
subpoenaed those notebooks and we
engaged in a ten month battle to get
them and ultimately the investigation
ended the subcommittee's mandate ended
we never got them on top of the fact
that clean copping why wasn't it pursued
at that time the administration to begin
with classified the notebooks and these
are this is truly bizarre because they
remained in Ali's possession at the
codeword level the
the expurgated copies were kept in your
committees office under codeword under
codeword classification when I read
those Diaries it wasn't exactly my said
your office you're in the sense of the
intelligence to nonce office German at
that time yes but and and that was quite
proper because those were the rules the
question the question I raised mr. Blum
is there are ways of dealing with claims
of executive privilege and they can be
taken to the courts and the courts have
a rule that the privilege is not
well-founded on some occasions and there
are remedies which the Senate can
undertake to deal with the
administration when the administration
acts improperly well we started down the
track the effort to get the subpoenas
became mired in the presidential
campaign and the political debate
surrounding it
the committee there's always one of
those going on the committees mandate
expired and frankly I can't tell you why
in the ensuing Congress it wasn't
pursued there was a later effort by the
National Security Archive under the
Freedom of Information Act to get
further declassification and release of
the notebooks they succeeded to some
degree the notebooks in their entirety
are still not public and my belief is
that your committee the Intelligence
Committee should undertake at the
earliest opportunity a complete
investigation of the notebook situation
and do your best to make it public to
restore some degree of confidence in the
process now the
the problem of general Noriega and Ollie
North's notebooks and what was in them
is only one of a number of problems
related to this war and related to drug
trafficking that we stumbled into we had
problems in Haiti where friends of ours
that is intelligent sources in the
Haitian military had turned their
facilities their ranches and their farms
over to drug traffickers instead of
putting pressure on that rotten
leadership of the Haitian military we
defended them we held our noses we look
the other way and they in their criminal
friends distributed through a variety of
networks cocaine in the United States in
Miami in Philadelphia New York in parts
of Pennsylvania Honduras was another
country that was key for the Contras
Honduras was the base of contra
operations most of the contra supplies
came through Honduras we wanted to do
nothing to embarrass the Honduran
military ramón matta-ballesteros a
member of the gang that was involved in
the Camarena murder went to Honduras and
found refuge there he was walking the
streets of Tegucigalpa openly and
publicly the response of the United
States government was to close the DEA
office in Honduras and move the agent
stationed there to Guatemala we took
testimony from that DEA agent he said it
made no sense the drug trafficking was
going on in Honduras the Honduran
military were at the center of it when
the war ended almost the minute the war
ended to our credit the administration
arranged the midnight extradition of mr.
Motta Ballesteros who is currently
serving a life term in American prisons
the response of the Honduran military
was to allow a mob to burn down a
portion of the US facilities in
Tegucigalpa but we sat by as long as
they were helping us and allowed them to
carry on their
business we also became aware of deep
connections between the law-enforcement
community and the intelligence community
I personally repeatedly heard from
prosecutors and people in the law
enforcement world that CIA agents were
required to sit in on the debriefing of
various people who were being questioned
about the drug trade they were required
to be present when witnesses were being
prepped for certain drug trials of
various at various times the
intelligence community inserted itself
in that legal process I believe that
that was an impropriety but that should
not have occurred well when you say when
you say in when you say inserted itself
into that process are you suggesting
that the intelligence community for
t'adore stop prosecutions not to on
forward that - that - well could you be
it let me explain
we're going to have to have this hearing
conducted without interruptions from the
audience if you are all here and you're
all invited to stay but if there are
interruptions we can clear the room
proceed mr. bloom there were first
participation zin the investigative
process a process and procedure for
clearing informants that were put on by
DEA a process of being therefore
debriefings of important witnesses but
then when there were criminal cases that
threatened to expose various covert
operations in the region those criminal
cases would be then put aside for one
reason or another and there was a
procedure for doing that within the
Department of Justice we attempted to
probe that procedure the Department of
Justice were buffed us rather
systematically we had some conversations
with one of the Justice Department
officials involved and took his
deposition but we were never able to get
really satisfactory responses to the
questions we
we do know that all a North directly
intervened in a number of cases to help
people who had helped the covert war mr.
Blum would you come to that subject
during my earlier tenure on this
committee I saw that done much to my
dissatisfaction there is a statute which
sets forth proceedings where the
Department of Justice is authorized to
drop prosecutions where they cannot make
disclosures of confidential informants
and I personally have questioned the
wisdom of that kind of a procedure but
it is authorized by US law and this
committee was frequently rebuffed by
claims of that sort but let me ask you a
question relevant here did you ever see
any of that interference by US
intelligence CIA or otherwise of any
prosecutions against cocaine in the Los
Angeles we did not focus on Los Angeles
and Los Angeles prosecutions I can tell
you there were cases in Miami and there
were other cases in other parts of the
country well I think we refer to them
and if you dig into the materials I
can't remember the more you say there
were not cases in Los Angeles I were
there we didn't find them that doesn't
mean there weren't any I understand that
but I'm asking whether you found them
but you say you did find such cases in
Miami now right did those cases permit
cocaine dealers to continue to operate
one had the sense they did but we could
not get when we got into this area we
confronted an absolute Stonewall bill
weld who was then the head of the
Criminal Division put a very serious
block on any effort we made to get
information there were stalls there were
refusal to talk to us refusals to turn
over data an assistant US attorney who
gave us some information was reprimand
and indisciplined even though it had
nothing to do with the case in a
confidential way and since we told us
about procedure
he I don't recall his name but it's in
our hearing materials and we can furnish
that for the record we had a series of
situations where Justice Department
people were told that if they told us
anything about what was going on they
would be subject to very severe
discipline and I got a lot of backdoor
information and then I was told I
couldn't ever use it because the careers
of the people involved would be
seriously compromised now we had another
problem with wait a minute when you were
told that did you make any efforts to
use that information yes what did you do
we went back to the Justice Department
we talked to them we said we really want
to talk to these people and they simply
stonewalled us now you're saying that he
received information on a voluntary
basis but under an agreement not to use
it because it would affect the careers
of those individuals right and you
honored we honored the we honored the
confidentiality it's the only way I'm
sure you understand that you can ever
get anyone to talk to you but then we
went back and tried to get the
information on the cases and as soon as
we did the answer was sorry we can't do
that and there were a thousand excuses
we ran into another procedure which was
extremely troubling there was a system
for stopping customs inspections of
inbound and outbound aircraft from Miami
and from other airports in Florida
people would call the customs office and
say stand down flights are going out
flights are coming in we tried to find
out more about that and were privately
told again by customs people who said
please don't say anything but the whole
thing was terribly informal and there
was no real way of determining the
legitimacy of the request to stand down
or the legitimacy of what was on the
plane and going out to people in the
field that I found to be terribly
troubling and it's a matter that you all
should be looking at very carefully
there was a flipside to this drug
problem as well one of the favored
techniques of various people in in this
operation was whatever there was someone
they didn't like they would label him a
drug trafficker so we ran into the case
of Ron Martin
who had set up an arm's warehouse in
Tegucigalpa Honduras and he did it at
the request of various friends of his in
the US government and it was sort of a
pre positioning of weapons to help the
Contras and the idea was that when the
ban on direct aid was lifted his stuff
could be sold Ron Martin was a potential
competitor of the Secord north supply
Network North started telling everyone
that the Martin warehouse was financed
by cocaine not to deal with it and the
impact was to destroy Ron Martin
financially so this became a matter of
affirmative and negative use I would say
that based on my experience with this
affair and my look at the long history
of our covert operations dealing with
criminals and drug dealers that this
entire affair needs a thorough review a
historical review as well as the narrow
review of the issues posed by the
article in the San Jose Mercury the
problem as I see it is if you go to bed
with dogs you get up with fleas if you
empower criminals because empowering
them happens to be helpful at the time
the criminals are sure to turn on you
next and the people who plan covert
operations should know that and should
be held accountable for not telling
their bosses if in fact they're dealing
with this kind of guy and they do come
back and bite them the most important
loss that we had as a result of the
covert war in Central America was the
loss of public trust in the honesty and
integrity of the people who run
America's clandestine operations the
measure of the
that is how ready everyone is to believe
freeway Ricky and his fable about being
the arm of the CIA and selling crack in
Los Angeles
Ricky deserves life in prison for what
he did to his people in his community
the CIA didn't make him do it and the
profits from his deal certainly didn't
go to help the conference but that does
not mean that there is not a need for a
very powerfully done investigation and a
backward look at the entire 40 year
history of this problem Thank You mr.
chairman uh we will proceed with
10-minute rounds as to your testimony
mr. Blum because it will differ
substantially in nature from mr. hits
and mr. brown which let me begin with
the overall question as to whether you
believe that the United States has now
placed proper emphasis on countering our
caller counter-narcotics is a foreign
policy goal yes I do I think the
priorities have changed very
substantially and I'm very pleased to
report that we have correctly now
assessed narcotics and international
organized crime as a significant threat
do you think the interdiction of the
international flow of narcotics has been
successful that we stopped
drugs from coming in from Latin America
we Mangano's we have terrible problems
in Mexico we have terrible problems in
still in Latin America and we have
problems coming at us in terms of heroin
from Asia and from Latin America as well
should the United States be doing more
to stop the flow of drugs into the
United States I think so yes
mr. bloom let me go back to the
specifics of the Mercury News series
because we are we are focused on that
here and you have raised quite a number
of other issues and they're all very
important but did the principal
participants in the current allegations
that is blended and
I figure in any of the investigation
which your subcommittee did yes as I
said we knew about Manassas I believe
one of Senator Kerry staff did an
interview Manassas at one point we were
aware of that cocaine ring and as I said
when we tried to get information through
government channels we were blocked was
there any information that you did get
that linked either blendin or Meneses to
the CIA not not directly no well
indirectly indirectly we would say I
would have to say yes and I hear hear
I'm relying on an eighth year an eighth
year memory when I say yes let me
explain what I mean we had people in the
confer movement southern front Contras
and indeed there's a television of video
deposition of one of them who says look
I discussed the problem of the drug
dealing among our number with my case
officer and he told me that was not who
was that who was on the video this this
is a con for a leader he was a member of
the contra Directorate we took his
deposition in video form in San Jose
Costa Rica do you recall his name not
off the top of my head okay I just I
just at the moment can't recall who it
was he told us that he had discussed the
drug problem and his case officer said
look there's nothing we can do about it
you do what you have to do just don't
tell me any more about he discussed the
drug problem with his case officer and
what kind of a case officer was CIA and
we have that just straight forward the
reaction of the people who were running
the covert operation as best as we could
determine was look we've been sent here
to Central America to do a job our job
is to win this war against the
Sandinistas and to change the political
climate here we're not in the law
enforcement business we can't be playing
cops
for the people who are working with us
if there's drug trafficking what the DEA
deal with them well we have to do what
we have to do and please don't let that
other mission interfere with what we
have to do because by god it's difficult
enough so what you're saying is that the
CIA individual did not stop him from
dealing in drug right but he did not
encourage him to deal drugs no or did
not use them but he then also excuse me
this is not finished or did not use the
proceeds or encourage the use of those
proceeds to finance the Contras
not at all and as I said before all of
the people who played in this took the
money and put it in their pockets now
there's there's one other thing you have
to understand about the situation on
Central America at the time and it's
relevant to the question you asked there
were facilities that were needed for
running the war clandestine tear strips
cowboy pilots who would fly junker
airplanes people who would make
arrangements for the clandestine
movement of money every one of those
facilities was a perfect facility for
someone in the drug business so there
were people who were connected very
directly to the CIA who had those
facilities and allowed them to be used
and indeed personally profited from
their use and happening do you have any
specifics on that I do and I will let me
let me finish the question who from the
CIA permitted those facilities to be
used it's not that someone from the CIA
permitted them to be used it's that a
contract employee had the facilities he
was doing a job that job wasn't
delivering drugs like an employee but
not a member of the CIA that's right and
I want to so the contract employee
allowed those facilities to be used and
the contract employee benefited from the
term you bet okay you bet and none of
that money went to the conference and I
I've shared with your staff the name of
a person involved I don't want to hear
violate the secrecy requirements that we
were bound by
the point is that this was going on in
tandem with the war and the people who
were organizing it from our side saw all
of it in fact you had to be blind not to
see it and instead of trying to stop it
or say wait a minute we really ought to
change our policy here or rethink how
we're doing it they went forward and
said we're going to solve the problem
with the Sandinistas and the devil take
this this other set of issues mr. Blum
referring now to some specific
individuals who have been who have been
cited in the Mercury News series Adolfo
Calero and in reak Bermudez were either
of those individuals involved in the
investigations which you conducted
certainly they were central figures in
the cultural movement and their names
came up
again and again in conversations about
the problem were they involved in
cocaine directly and directly to my
knowledge I know I have to say no all
right indirectly to your knowledge there
are many of their people and their close
associates work but how about those
individuals specifically I can't say
that I have evidence of it and who among
their close associates were involved we
have listed people in the report we have
additional material and you'll find it
in our transcripts after eight years I
can't list names and if I did I'd be
taking a terrible risk well I can
understand that or any of those
individuals identified in the San Jose
Mercury series not to my recollection no
going back to the issue of covert
operations of mr. Bloem base based on
what you have found do you think the
United States Congress as a matter of
public policy ought to ban covert
operations
I think that there may in some
circumstances desperate matters of
national urgency be some kind of
argument for them but I will say that in
my experience we have rarely considered
a blowback we have rarely considered the
long-term political consequence and if
you look at the kind of catastrophic
record that the operations that got us
tangled up in the drug business led to I
would say they failed remember we lost
the war in Nicaragua remember that our
dear friends in the Argentine military
disappeared thousands of people look at
the horrible brutal reality of
Pinochet's Chile and ask what kind of
threat there was to the United States
that warranted that kind of behavior
well I come to the I come to the public
policy question because this committee
has been very deeply involved and it's
continuing at this moment on a valuation
of what may or may not be covert
activities and I'm interested in your
judgment I your but your net conclusion
is that there are some situations which
may be sufficiently serious to warrant
overt activities there may be but but I
believe but nowhere near the scale not
even a smidgen of the scale but they
were carried out on in the past and
certainly a complete rethink of the idea
of building alliances with criminals and
drug dealers well are you think we need
to spend much more money on overt
diplomacy and on public health for
people who are our friends and on real
diplomacy we've slashed the State
Department budget by a tremendous amount
and not on the same for the intelligence
budget I find that quite mysterious do
you think we have slashed the State
Department too much in the past several
years way too much there's no money for
people to travel no money for them to
negotiate no money to bring foreign
leaders here to teach them to educate
them no opportunity to bring your
merging leadership here we
have a very real budgetary problem my
time is up and I want to just ask you
two very pointed questions when you say
that there have been too many covert
activities are you aware of how many
covert activities there have been
because the findings are secret they're
made by the president they're supposed
to be secret there are a fair number
that do remain secret believe it or not
because this committee does review them
so I just wonder what well basis may be
you know no no no wait a minute let me
finish the question so the question is
what is your basis of knowledge as to
the covert activities which are which
have been undertaken to say that there
are too many I have now spent a number
of years in the field that is traveling
around the world talking to people I
will give you just one experience with
Washington's notion of secrecy and the
world's notion of secrecy it was one of
my first trips to Asia in the middle of
the Vietnam War I was on a KLM plane
flying over Vietnam the pilot Dutch said
ladies and gentlemen look outside the
window were flying over Laos see that
area it's been carpet bombed I came back
to Washington and I said to Senator
Symington I was then working for the
Senate senator you know were bombing in
Laos
he said that's classified now I submit
to you again he'd of like KLM I submit
to you that lots of what you sit here
and look at and say boy this is
classified it's code word it's secret
they can only be talked about in a skiff
by people who've had their backgrounds
investigated to the nth degree out in
the field is being talked about at 40
decibels of a saloon somewhere let me
come back to that it's a it's a fairly
involved subject which I do want to
pursue with you but I want to yield at
this time to settle concurring thank you
very much miss Campbell miss bloom the
record should show I disagree with you
on that on that point there are people
out there who are get considerable
risk and if what you said was true they
wouldn't be alive
so I met I just let the record show that
I disagree with what he just said first
mr. bloom can you tell me it seems to me
that the subcommittee and on that
committee at the time Senator John Kerry
of Massachusetts Brock Adams Washington
our Moynihan of New York on the ranking
side was congressman Senator McConnell
of Kentucky and Senator Murkowski of
Alaska it seems to me that the
recommendation is I want to I want to
give you an opportunity to talk about
this it seems to me the subcommittee was
successful in some areas in other words
that there were some policy changes that
occurred both in law and on the
administrative side as a consequence of
the subcommittee's work is that is that
correct I hope so well answer is yes I
think we did begin to to change the
public perception of the foreign policy
issues I think we did begin to get
people to understand the dimension of
the drug problem and refocus on the drug
problem but but there was very specific
administrative recommendations and very
specific legislative recommendations
that were made do you know mr. Blum how
many of those administrative
recommendations and how many those
legislative recommendations were either
accepted by the executive branch or
enacted by the legislature I can't
really tell you that I left in 1989 and
did not handle the follow through I
think some of them were considered maybe
some of them were adopted but I don't
think they were all accepted readily I
think we had some changes but they were
not really very dramatic well would you
be prepared to to evaluate this or
perhaps I should just ask the Foreign
Relations Committee to do a trip I think
that it would be more appropriate since
the means to evaluate them I know we
made on our historic because I look as I
look through the list and there's one
two three four five six seven on the
administrative side and one two three
four five six seven eight on the
legislative side as I look at the list
there are a number of them that I
recognize immediately as being current
US policy and so it seems to me that
that it's likely to be the case that a
number of these recommendations were
made both by the executive branch and by
the legislative branch in response to
the subcommittee's work I think that
there were changes and I think the
earrings did have a positive impact
secondly a mr. bond come you talked to
me you said that there was a systematic
effort to discredit the work of the the
subcommittee and you separately
mentioned that there was a refusal by
the Department of Justice to visit
justice justice provide you with
information that you needed right is
that correct can you can you tell me put
a little more detail on what you mean by
systematic so some examples we would
want to know systemic to me means that
there was there was an organized effort
towards that is that actually woven away
and I would you define systematic an
organized effort from the top who was in
charge of it as best I could tell it was
coming from the top of the criminal
division who is the top the colonel
vision bill weld as and and when you say
the effort was made what would they do
they call if they would tell us
attorneys systematically you can't talk
to them you know don't give them paper
don't cooperate don't let them have
access to people who you have in your
control and we had a very tough time
finding things out certainly a mr. Bloem
I don't want to get into a great deal of
argument about this but I think it might
be important just in the standpoint of
your evaluation of when a in a covert
environment us personnel should say that
we're going to provide this information
to law enforcement in order to be able
to in order to be able to bring a
conviction it seems to me you're saying
this is one of the trickiest questions
in the law enforcement intelligence
agency world and I should spend a minute
give you a just a little bit of the
flavor of why it's so devilish well I
actually you needn't give me a minute
because I could give you an hour as I
understand that it's devilish that what
I'm what's your view mr. Bloem of the
contra policy itself you did you support
at the time the contra policy do you
believe it carry
high-priority Chinese good thought but
next to other things that were going on
in the hemisphere of the problem of a
sandanista government Nicaragua was
really the low end of the scale but did
you did you think the Contra effort I
understand that but did you did you
think the contractor was worthwhile did
you support it I didn't think it was
worthwhile it is to take any position on
it publicly I thought that it was a
wrong wrong affair but I my business was
to find out what was going on in the
drug trade and we looked not only at the
confer problem but we looked at drugs
going through Cuba drugs going through
the Bahamas and all of the different
national security issues that were
tangled up in in those as well so and we
had bipartisan support this was not a
political effort to unstring the Contra
war it was a political effort to
understand how it could have come to
pass that we had tons of cocaine in
Miami and people instead of trying to
solve that problem were telling law
enforcement people to look in a
different direction can you imagine a
scenario mr. Blum under which you would
say that the objective the foreign
policy objective was so important that
it would in fact be a higher priority
than the law enforcement effort here's
my problem I think that if people in the
government of the United States make a
secret decision to sacrifice some
portion of the American population in
the form of exposing them let's say
deliberately exposing them to drugs that
is a terrible decision that should never
be made in you saying it
now I want to be clear I'm not saying
I'm not saying I'm not saying here that
there was such a secret essential then
why did you make the statement but let
me explain amid no explanation well it
did I drew a wonderful round instrument
that I'm not trying to draw a round of a
well I'm trying to blind on just a
minute mr. Blum let's let the Senator
Kerry finish his question I mean I mean
you you made a statement that that was
was in the context of this overall
discussion of what's going on with the
the CIA's efforts in the Contra policy
and and it seemed to leave the
impression at least that US policymakers
consciously sacrificed a portion of the
US population
this Chairman I will say to members I I
support the Chairman when he says this
this public hearing has to be conducted
it with some civility in the audience is
is welcomed and invited here but I'll
support the Chairman's a decision to
clear this room if we continue to get
interruptions it does not work for us
you heard my opening statement we're not
trying to cover up anything well as
chairman this chairman I
hmm well they may have a an opportunity
to UM my judgment is that we ought to
proceed there's a lot of public interest
in this matter we want people to be
present we can't identify who say what
we're not going to get into any
investigations we just ask for your
cooperation
and allowing us to proceed with the
questions without a response to the
extent that you can I would like to try
to answer that as best I can
when people who are engaged in an
operation say we're going to look the
other way we're not going to do anything
interfere in the law enforcement process
to protect people who are running the
operation and in that process of
interference permit drugs to flow in you
have an extraordinarily serious problem
now the DEA when it has on any bump let
me get you back to the question I asked
right I don't disagree with your
statement if you listen to the audience
listed who keeps you interrupting with
their enthusiastic support of what you
said earlier I I do think it is a
terrible mistake to say that we're going
to allow drug trafficking to destroy
American citizens as a consequence of
believing that the controvert was a
higher priority I ask you a question
the question is this do you in your own
mind have a situation obviously you were
at best lukewarm to the contrary effort
you see in your own mind risk to the
people of this country that would carry
with it a high enough priority that in
that circumstance you believe that it
would not be wise to bring the evidence
out and pursue a prosecution and that in
that case in the rear let me give you an
example how about nuclear nuclear
proliferation how about and how about it
how about a covert operation that's
designed to interrupt and and and to
prevent the flow of chemical and
biological agents in the United States
in that situation mr. Bloem in that
situation mr. Blum what is your view if
they if the people are involved that
uncover evidence that might lead to a
prosecution should they shut down the
operation
I understand that and there are
circumstances where I would agree that
you would shut down a prosecution but
you don't do it on the question isn't is
there a bright line and can we draw a
bright line right there was a judgment
call here and that judgment call erred
so far on the wrong side of where
judgment should have been that we wound
up with a terrible problem and that
terrible problem was a de facto result
that I was describing that is where many
people did suffer as a consequence and I
started to say when DEA allows a
controlled delivery of drugs there is a
furious debate those control deliveries
are monitored because DEA says our job
is to prevent it from coming in and if
it escapes on the street for any reason
we've blown it and that kind of standard
is really the kind of standard that
should have I think been applied here
and maybe you can give me and maybe we
would both agree that there is some
dreadful circumstance where they should
have occurred and been allowed to occur
and so on
and I probably could be convinced in the
right set of circumstances but the
problem was that that issue wasn't put
that way and the sensitivity to what was
going on was simply miscible thank you
thank you very much senator Kerry a
senator Rob mr. chairman I think that I
will defer any questioning it at this
point I think the challenge to the
committee has been sufficiently
articulated and I think the sensitivity
and volatility of the concerns are such
that it would be appropriate to have the
two inspectors general complete their
work before at least as far as my own
participation is concerned it is the
matters that are under discussion are
extremely serious and I think they
deserve as factual an investigation as
we can provide and I'm not sure that
attempting to come to conclusions at
this point would advance the cause that
I know that the chairman and the vice
chairman seek in holding these
particular greeings I would I would ask
a procedural question perhaps to mr.
bloom it and that is whether or not you
believe that the authority of the
inspectors general is sufficient to
provide the kind of answers and the kind
of objectivity that that your concerns
have addressed to whatever conclusions
this committee might draw from those
reports I think that the authority is
sufficient as far as the behavior of
people who are employees of a specific
agency in question of the Justice
Department or the CIA the rest of the
question which is of a political level
at the NSC and the policy decisions
taken will undoubtedly wind up in that
realm of executive privilege and top
secrecy and therein lies the very great
difficulty in expecting the inspectors
general to solve the problem I think we
can find out whether CIA employees
follow the rules I don't think that the
Inspector General can tell you all about
what Ollie north did and didn't do or
what what what was going on in that
circle of people and who they brought in
and and what they told people to do and
we know enough now to know that many
people played out of channels and did
things out of channels or didn't
necessarily report them so I I have a
sense you can get a good part of the way
I'm not at all sure you can get all of
the way this Chairman I think that I
will persist in withholding at this
point I do have a couple of particles
that I was going to use as the basis for
questions that I would like to simply
provide to the those who are going to
conduct the investigations to consider
as a part of
any other information they may bring to
bear on their investigations and I will
await a formal completion of their
activities I know that they haven't had
an opportunity to speak formally yet but
some indication of when they believe
that their reports would be available
would be useful at least to me in terms
of figuring out what kind of time frame
we're talking about getting the kinds of
facts that would hopefully address and
perhaps put to rest some of the
questions that have been raised senator
Robb we will address that time for you
what they expect to do Thank You mr.
chairman like you said of the ROM mr.
Blum just a few more questions
coming back to the end point of my
inquiries as to covert actions and you
gave the one illustration as to klm and
I think it is obvious that there are
covert activities which are known beyond
the realm of secrecy but your critique
is very forceful and it may well be that
the Congress oughta make some different
conclusions as to covert activities so
that's why I was asking you the basis
for your statement that there are too
many covert activities as a
generalization the covert activities
you're only known to the oversight
committees the covert activities are
undertaken after a finding by the
presidents of people in the executive
branch no and we have some oversight and
it is true that sometimes covert
activities are disclosed in the public
media but it is a relatively rare
occurrence considering how many there
are so that's why I asked you the
question to what extent do you know of
the covert activities to come to a
judgment that there are too many in
there too far feds you know what I
should be doing is paying much more
careful attention to language and I
understand that in in defining a covert
activity you have a very specific
definition in mind the question may turn
more on relationships and ongoing
Arrangements than specific presidential
eoz covert activities
so on the question of protecting our
friends in different places whether
they've been engaged in human rights
violations or in drug trafficking
violations there may not be a covert
activity as defined by law as authorized
by the president but there may be
ongoing relationships this may be a
definitional question I may be saying
something different than what you mean I
can't tell you though that I know and I
don't want to deceive you I don't know
what has gone on in the executive branch
in secret I have not been privy to the
findings and I don't want to mislead you
well it is a different matter as to
whether there are human rights
violations which are not being pursued
and this committee has been very
diligent in our pursuit for example of
what goes on in Guatemala and the
committee used to be on behind closed
door I'm sorry in here and the committee
is to be commended for did repeat that
it's quite all right you you had made
had made a comment about things that
were taught to people that were hard to
erase from their minds and one of them
was to teach people how to assassinate
other people do you have any evidentiary
basis for a conclusion that the United
States is seeking to assassinate someone
contrary certainly US policy certainly
not not currently but I refer you back
to the Church Committee investigation
unfamiliar yeah I knew you are so that's
so that's about that's a historical base
for from which I'm I'm talking I'm not
talking about currently that was
specifically prohibited and that problem
was addressed mr. Blum in the course of
the report which was filed by the
Subcommittee on terrorism narcotics and
international operations what is the
most explicit statement if you could
give it to us on a finding that US
intelligence forces were permitting
people working for them to engage in
drug activities
I think I have to let the language of
the report speak for itself and I'll say
why that report went through so many
editorial changes that even after
reading it I can't remember which
version got to where the the report does
speak for itself the problem that we saw
and we could definitely speak to and I
know the report speaks to it is the
problem of standing by when you knew
that people were doing the drug were in
the drug business when you were an
employee of the government well that's a
very very very very enough for a tough
problem very serious matter are you
suggesting that it was stated more
explicitly but it was cut out on the
editorial process no I think we were
pretty I think it is there but we
believed that the government that is the
CIA was aware of this problem was aware
of trafficking by people and I think we
said that I I don't think that that's
something that was added it out I don't
what remark or what you're referring to
with respect to the question of what
policymakers have have done
do you have an evidentiary base for
concluding that the policymakers were
aware that the intelligence operatives
were allowing drugs to be disseminated
certainly in the case of general Noriega
Biasi no question of them beyond general
Noriega my guess is and it's it's a
guess but I think a very educated guess
that in the case of Honduras yes in the
case of Haiti yes they knew they knew
there was a problem how about with
specific reference to the distribution
of drugs say in Los Angeles I don't
think they were ever given a clean
understanding of the full implications
of what was policymakers was right with
respect to with respect to Colonel north
and there you raised a very very serious
questions
and the Congress had said there'd be no
more support for the Contras I voted
with the majority on that opposed to
supporting the Contras
there was a select committee which
investigated that matter the
investigation was started by the
Intelligence Committee when I was on an
early stage that it was my hope that the
Intelligence Committee would have
pursued that but Select Committee took
over and you had access to challenge the
refusal of the executive branch to turn
over information to you let me tell you
this mr. Blum that's going on today
Senator Kerry and I are fighting with
many of the department's of the
executive branch about not disclosing
materials to us and it is an
extraordinarily laborious process and I
believe that started in George
Washington's day it didn't been going on
a long time in us